here's bringing you back bringing you
back mike to you
he's looking at kevin gates over here i
was a fools
kevin gates smart got this [ __ ] together
i ain't about to say that i ain't got my
[ __ ] together yeah
i'm trying
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome to this
episode of hotbox with mike tyson i'm
your co-host aka triple c henry cejudo
i'm mike tyson
we got the baddest [ __ ] rap
right now man
brother kevin gates case brother how you
doing what's up man come on let's get a
round of applause here what's up
everybody what's up it's sleeping mike
what's up all right
like i'm just really taking it all in
and thank you for having me
[ __ ] we love you [ __ ] i love you more
fans with that where you from
louisiana louisiana rouge louisiana
baton rouge
i was in new orleans with baby and i'm
from
that's where i started in new orleans
but i spent more
relatively more time in baton rouge yeah
did you hook up with baby and none of
them i'm after peeing them i met them
i don't know all of them i met them
before i know
the young kid when they were doing that
yeah they're older than me i
know [ __ ] yeah they are yeah so kevin
tell us a little bit about your
uh your upbringing and how it was uh
growing up in the south and
i'm gonna be i'm gonna be honest with
you like
this is gonna be a different type of
interview because i'm gonna like
i'm gonna tell the absolute truth so
tell me about that [ __ ]
it's a real racist place like being in
the we just being down south period
and i'm still kind of breaking that that
stereotype you know in my mind
still kind of breaking like it's a
barrier it's unspoken
looking yourself as an activist never no
the greatest teachers teach without
teaching i don't want to get a
standard no pool pit in and and be like
hey y'all follow me
just just just look at the way i live my
life and judge me based on that
i know that's not how it goes it doesn't
go the way we want it to go yeah
you see you i'm going to follow him you
can't stop them from falling
it's just that way yeah that's a field
man
you know it's all love yeah i don't want
to be no leader i never wanted to be no
big leader
oh man you're already a leader what do
you want to do
unfortunately no i'm coming from what
you do
but it's been adorned on you by god yeah
so
you know i mean you think god made a
mistake you're muslim man i know you
know
i know you know better you just talking
hollywood stuff but you know
now i'm gonna be honest with you though
that's that's been one of my biggest
fears
people following me like all my life i
knew i was chosen
i knew i used to do [ __ ] to to kind of
sabotage my path to sabotage my career
same thing i used to i used to sabotage
my own career i would get in my own way
to keep from having to carry out this
great responsibility that god bestowed
upon me
it's called what was it called
survivor's guilt
you ever heard about that you heard that
survivor's guilt no sir
that um you feel guilty that you made in
the mother guys what you didn't make it
they were smarter than you had more
organization than you but you made it
right
and more family than you more everything
mortality more everything than you
but they didn't make it but it was but
it was set for them to make it had
everything to make it that you did but
you made it
right did you have that mike did you did
you feel that
would he talk about it yeah but i
thought i knew i was special i used to
always think i was jim brown and jim
kelly from three the hallway and [ __ ]
yeah you know but i was in my mind like
if somebody picked them in the street
i'd be scared and run or something
it was always in my mind and when i had
that first fight when the guy killed my
pigeon
it was over first time i was like i had
to fight fought everything i almost had
three four fights a day
as i was i wanted because i just saw
your documentary on cbs i did a good job
is that when you f is that when you
discovered your ability mike
yeah and so the guys that used to pick
on me taught me how to
you know hit guys knock out and go in
their pockets and get their money
so they the guy used to pick on me after
i started fighting back
they became my friend then they showed
me the ropes how to rob houses how to
pickpocket snatch chains and all that
stuff
oh damn like that became my friend
yeah how did this unfold for you kevin
with
with the rap career obviously it took
something devastating for mike you know
you know somebody killing this pigeon
you know enough for him to discover you
know the sport of boxing
for you as a kid man what what what
brought you into to the rap game
it was an escape for me and i'm gonna
say
i never said this in no interview no
podcast or anything like that
i grew up real real violent and real
aggressive
not because i wanted to be but i was
molested when i was a child
so i had this fear of being vulnerable
so i took all every kind of martial arts
you could take and
i even boxed i did everything and i
wanted to be the toughest person on
earth
but writing and making music was always
an escape for me
like i never had the like the nuts to
come out and say that
this is my first time saying this today
since i've yeah but i know i know that i
know that route too
why do you think i became the meanest
[ __ ] on the planet
somebody did something to me yes sir and
i didn't want to happen again so i
became
this guy yeah take it to the furthest
extent
yeah yes sir that's my that's my story
that's after but it was really
it was really everything that i did even
like people say
like kevin gates he just killed i'm not
i'm not
but the reason i speak about it not
because i just released a mixtape like
maybe
may a few months ago and guys walk up to
me in the gym like bodybuilders
and just hug me and cry and be like man
i went through the same [ __ ] you went
through like
keep doing what you doing so i'm like i
guess i'm on the right path
yo you're really politic out there in
the music world man
i mean when we first started so who's
that that's kevin gates kevin gates i
thought you have a fancy rap name name
the king shabbat or something
it's kevin gates playing old kevin it's
all
good yes you've had a lot you know
looking up your story man you've uh
you know you're you're muslim too on uh
yes
yeah the devoted as much as i can
once as you can i guess for everybody
you know what i'm saying mike like he's
uh
he's in the game and it's uh god just
wants him to say
he you know me he's in control you know
god
elijah wants him to know that he follows
our law law just wants to love him
that's all
allah knows what we're doing before we
were even born he knew we were going to
do what we're going to do what we do be
judged by the intentions of our heart
and our heart alone
but we try we do well we do good
you're not fighting with no one are you
no no other rapper anything are you
i don't involve myself in it
[Laughter]
yeah how would you describe your uh how
would you describe yourself as an artist
kevin right now yeah of course
or maybe from then to now i'm living an
absolute truth right now
like i'm naked right now
i'm free this is free kevin tell me
about yourself how was your sales on
your new album
i never paid attention to myself but we
got your tape
okay a new joint
i never paid attention i don't even get
lost in sales no
it's about this are you good for love it
gotta come from the heart
the money gonna come as long as the dope
good it's gonna always sell itself
i just want everything i just want the
sales i want everything i'm such a
glutton
you need a lot of your uh you know you
obviously you have two kids man tell us
about uh i have four kids
one kid all right okay but you have you
named a couple
albums or a couple of song names after
your kids right well
the album that i just dropped the first
album i dropped was isla
and i named that after my daughter and
the album that i'm about to drop now is
nan kaza
after my son and the names are so
different man
well they both they both are big names
yeah like isla is like to
to critique to make better and
like a like a epiphany a great awakening
and my daughter did all of those things
for me in kaza
it means like powerful like a great
treasure
yeah that's what he is to me
how do you feel like that with your kids
mike you know obviously mike's got seven
kids
my kids yeah that's interesting i'm a
ketchup
i have to be very careful with my kids
because i forget sometimes i'm me and um
i forget that i'm mike tyson that guy
the overpow
powering father and stuff so i gotta be
very
gentle with them because they may take
it personal yeah cause i do remember
i do remember yesterday we're talking
mike and it's like with mike because
he's you know he's such a public figure
that uh
you know he walks on the street people
you know people surround him
and what happens and i i i was very
heartfelt with mike was saying is that
his kids
you know it's because it happens to me
every once in a while but like his kids
are kind of like they leave and
everybody else is like there he's like
why are you guys leaving man
you know what i'm saying like they're
not used to all these people they always
want to be with me they don't want to be
all these people just
it's just it just don't rub them well
they feel isolated they don't feel like
they're part of me
right yeah and that's not that's not a
good feeling do you ever do you ever
feel like that as
a public figure man like having well
working on this album right now i've
been traveling everywhere
and just working wherever i go like i'm
an energy person i'm not trying to sound
like a tree hugger or anything like that
but
i'm an energy person if the energy good
i'm there
and i've been away from my children and
sometimes i feel like
man i'm a bad father because i'm away
from my children that's the hardest
thing for me
is being away from my children i don't
like that either
yeah i don't like it i'm like i didn't
have a father growing up
so i you know yes i was always locked up
so i never saw my family much i was a
kid
yeah man to talk talk to us a little bit
about uh because
you don't only i mean you've been
dabbling on that you have a blueberry
farm
oh yes sir yeah what do you mean like
the fruit blueberries yeah like
what it sounds like i'm talking they
look like grapes
really they big what did you do to make
them look like great
and we just love the land yeah we love
the land
it's you know just the energy that we
put into the land
but what was it about do you have that
entrepreneur spirit like you want do you
are you are you trying to dabble into
everything not really
it's just really been by following my
heart lately because
like i didn't got caught up in the fame
[ __ ] already i didn't got caught up in
instagram i just
reactivated my page from having it i was
gone off instagram for like six months
and i just i wanted to know me
i wanted to be free all the way in this
entirety
and we didn't even know that we was
going to do what we did with the farm
that was just our dream
and i was incarcerated at the time and
drinker purchased the farm
and when she purchased the farm i was
like man it was just flat land and
a puddle the lake wasn't even dug out
yet
yeah and then it was already a blueberry
farm but nobody had loved on the land
yeah and it just turned into something
amazing like
even with us having camels and alpacas
man what [ __ ] do you know with camels
no i don't know them [ __ ] with campbell
unless he's in [ __ ] saudi arabia
of egypt somewhere what [ __ ] do you
know with cowboys tell me about the do
they spit i wasn't a camel once in egypt
but they just wasn't fun
nah they don't spit they kind of mo the
closest thing i could relate it to is
like having a dog
but they super smart they see something
three times
it's law with them i'm gonna go to
seattle and see my horses i bought some
horses
i just came from seattle i caught a
flight from seattle to come here that's
where i've been at
yeah kevin it almost seems like
manhattan it's almost it almost feels
like this pandemic like you went on a
kind of soul-searching night i feel like
i get that vibe from you like these last
uh
this was the pandemic the best thing
that could happen to you this was before
the pandemic but the pandemic was the
best thing that ever happened to me
yeah cause you went from a 310 pounds
and i was 310. yeah but i know what look
up
who's that you said me yeah that's
that's the old kevin and what do you
weigh now
maybe 205 210 i don't know so you just
got rid of a human off you dude you know
what i'm saying that's
315 pounds dude 310 i mean 110 pounds
how was how was it for you mike to get
all that weight to get all that weight
off
it was beautiful how big did you get
mike
what's the biggest you've ever gotten i
don't know 310 315.
if you had the opportunity to meet the
be some of your idols man have you
had a chance to collaborate with little
wayne you know yeah we've worked
together yeah
and birdman all those dudes yeah we've
worked together also
yeah i really worked with everybody
nicki minaj you know
no i never worked with her that would be
cool huh yeah it would be
come on kevin we gotta show someone your
[ __ ] thing baby
i'll work out to that cartel swag you
forgot to get some thin stuff baby
kevin gates cartel swag that's what i
work out to right now
man you know what i'm really curious
about man like really tugs at me
you know the the faith man you know
because i notice you put a you know
there's arabic in your music
pretty much everything is arabic in it
like and those
the average that you can be speaking
those are prayers like
prayers like surahs like they come from
the koran
yeah you can relate right mike big time
what was it with you mike that sparked
you and uh will you raise muslim mike or
was it something that uh
nice all my friends were all friendly to
rob and
hustle it was muslims and stuff muslim
fiber sinners
back in the seventies yeah your big uh
your legend your you're idleman ali
yeah ali was uh that's who i am though
it's just who i am
what in the religion it's just who i am
what's what's next kevin what's next for
you man what's what's next on the
horizon do you want me to be honest with
you
i don't know what i'm doing i'm just
i don't know what i'm doing but i know
i'm on the right path
i tell my wife that all the time because
my wife is my wife to listen so um
sometimes we have um we're we're
enterprise now you know now i'm
corporate guys so every now and then we
have people that say mike
i want to invest in you and do this and
i and what do you want to do and i would
say
if someone has a billion dollars they
say hey mike here what do you want to do
i would say i don't know nothing nothing
right
and my wife gets back and i say whatever
i want it just comes to me i don't
go out and get it it comes to me store
my life you know what man
do you understand what i'm saying no
listen it comes to me whatever i want
i get it yeah i don't want to talk about
it
whatever that's crazy yeah but i also
think too sometimes mike is you probably
already imagined in your head
you just don't play like the normal
human no that's a normal person probably
would so this is what i do now
when it comes to me i give it right to
my wife my wife knows what to do with
the money see i don't i feel
uncomfortable taking money and stuff
but then one of my friends said if you
don't take money from a friend or take
favors from a friend and you're not
really a friend so i have to take money
to make this guy believe i'm just it's
just i don't like that soul stuff
yeah it's hard for me to accept to
accept things from people because
in my mind i'm always what's going to
come behind this
i just feel like i feel emotional like
it's a pride thing with me
like i don't the worst thing i can do is
ask somebody for something
even if i really need help i got to
really swallow my pride and ask for help
no but i think it's important what mike
said yeah yeah i think i think
it's like if you can't accept from a
friend then you're really not a friend
that hurt me i knew i wanted to have a
way probably i wanted to use prior to
when my friend said how could you be my
friend if you want to accept
a friend a friend's deed then i said
well you're right
yeah it's almost like this like true
humbleness
is not somebody that boasts about his
success or he's got you know gold
you know what i'm saying like a true
humbleness is somebody that asks for
help do you
like you know what i'm saying like true
humbleness is somebody that's that's
that's honest would you would you say
mike like that's
right i'm weak man i need help or you
know what i'm saying i don't look at
that like
humble no that ain't humble you just a
[ __ ] that need help
i look at humble as when you can be a
legend and you grading
like when rudyard kipling said in that
poem if if you could walk amongst kings
but not lose the commoners touch then
you will be a man my son i don't think
it's
important seriously that's that's what i
look at as being humble like
you know i go walk on water right now
but i hate i'll probably say it's only
cause i can't swim
but i'm super humble i try because all i
can do is try my best
so that's what i look at is being humble
like not bragging and boasting on myself
yeah
i'm humble i carry myself in humility
that's why i don't have to have
50 bodyguards because i know how to
stand and greet a man whenever he walk
in the room
well i give most of my money to cherry
cause i just can't be humble i just
gotta talk some [ __ ]
hey we gotta turn up gotta talk about
charity and stuff
but that's what this will be and well
let's break it down then being humble
just means being
i'm entertaining people i don't really
mean this [ __ ] yeah you got to turn up
some time though
but when you do mike you got to turn
those
100 000
[Laughter]
yeah you have any good memories in mike
man watching him uh did you watch my
back in the you're 35 right 20 years
yeah he was
i was 20 years old when he was born yeah
i watched mike
you're born in 86 87 huh that girl in
the audience she's gonna take him home
and do all kinds of nasty things to him
so long as they call him champ
that's when you have fought on mitch
green i think oh god mitch green is so
sick
he's a born again christian now he's the
minister now no way
hell yeah baby [ __ ] i i watched
you know my grandmother used to
my grandmother gangsta yeah my
grandmother real gangster
so she was that's how i got nature oh
she was just sure
yeah he fighting baby any muslim look he
going all the way on the ground with it
do you do you still keep in contact with
some people that you fought you still
came in contact with the larry holmes or
anybody like that you fought mike
no i guess um it's um
work hard to take care of a family
that's my only purpose in life
yeah but i'm saying like no like in the
boxing community do you ever do you ever
cross paths with these guys are you guys
stupid
if i ever wish i'd never do i ever go to
a boxing match i may see some people
yeah the guys that i i fight with
they're not in my circles now
they don't very few if any i've ever
seen they don't hang around where i
do i have to at yeah because it's almost
like i don't know if the
sometimes i don't know if the rivalries
because i just retired i don't know if
their rivalries
just exist like will they exist forever
do you think like there's
you may not like somebody but you got to
respect them anybody that's ever fought
to anybody that you've ever fought mike
you respect
listen um if i see somebody out for and
also i'm not doing that good i will [ __ ]
gym ten if i have money i break them off
you know everybody doesn't do well you
know i'm very i miss a really
i'm at the dick that's lucky you know
what i mean
you're blessed yeah you blessed look
i'm like i'm just i was good
i went that route i made i had that 400
million i blew it
right it took around 11 years to do it
though but i blew it
it could be done [ __ ] you can blow a
billion dollars in like
two days a month trust me lose some
money [ __ ] and then after you lose that
billion dollars
um the world said that's all you got
the world can take it all that's all you
got a billion dollars it looks at you
and laughs
yeah you know we blew a billion dollars
in the world that's all you got
right we're about to commit suicide
that's all yeah
you know some pretty crazy things with
your stuff uh
yeah it probably took you a minute to
kind of you know mature right as a
you said you're a different rapper than
you are than you were then yeah i'm way
different
how much different have you uh have you
been these last
five six years i'm gonna say i'm i'm
super interesting
but the [ __ ] that i do most rappers
don't do like i get up at 4 30 in the
morning and go jogging and go work out
like before i came here i worked out
because that's my therapy
so i work out i go hiking i do [ __ ] that
most rappers ain't gonna do
i don't drink i don't smoke you know
what i'm saying
i like going [ __ ] off and try different
types of coffees
i'm a cheeseburger fanatic i love to go
try
like different types of cheeseburgers
what kind of you got this cheeseburger
and [ __ ] and i'm in the cheeseburger
i'm telling you back in the day and then
i like to get fly i just
you know i don't know what it is i like
to get flying just go places just by
myself and just
[ __ ] off i do [ __ ] most rappers don't do
yeah
[ __ ] man you got a bunch of [ __ ]
don't you
right now you got a bunch of [ __ ]
i've had some no they never go away once
you got them they're there forever
well yeah you know you just have to warn
them i know
i'm so blessed that anything i touch is
going you know it's a life-altering
experience it's all beautiful i know it
must be beautiful brother
to be young it's a life alternative it's
a life-changing experience
here's bringing you back bringing you
back mike to you
he's looking at kevin gates over here i
was a fools
kevin gates smart got this [ __ ] together
i didn't give a [ __ ]
i ain't about to say that i ain't got my
[ __ ] together yeah [ __ ]
i put a lot of cars damn man i don't
know i just feel cheated if i gave you
the money
and you ain't giving me the same
experience that i gave you
because i changed your life you never
had an orgasm before you came around me
and i
did all this [ __ ] for you and gave you
the money
listen when i was doing that stuff we
can't even talk about that stuff on the
camera now
yeah like i didn't i didn't bless your
soul and you just don't just take my
money like no
you should pay me like i don't know i'm
gonna enlighten this soul
the enlightened soul that's called
all day coming up here this is the
closest to god you're gonna ever be
like i agree i agree you're the image of
god in the in human form brother
you think uh you think tick tock has uh
has influenced a lot of you guys music
your music in particular you think it's
you think it's helped everything no
that's gonna sound crazy
i'm not even on social media at all
that [ __ ] is depressing cause you
you once you look at what other people
are doing i compare my real life to
their highlight reel
and then i start making comparisons and
comparisons is the killer of all joy
so every day i wake up i try to find my
gratitude i don't give a [ __ ] what's
going on on social media
i'm verified in the streets see i don't
know how to turn on the only thing i
know how to do is turn in i don't know
how to work the computer
got a spell [ __ ] i can't spell [ __ ] yeah
all that [ __ ]
yeah you don't get on there look at your
instagram every once in a while i get
somebody look at it for me to turn get
on there and
put it on so what's up man who you be
seeing around there what kind of hot
chicks you see in the rap world
i don't see nobody to be honest none of
them [ __ ] [ __ ] look the [ __ ]
you gonna tell me that
i don't see nobody i'm dead serious
i don't do rapper [ __ ] like i don't even
go to clubs
what the [ __ ] you do [ __ ] you do it you
just um
you're exposed to the life the elements
man what do you do
just i don't know it's just like the way
that i live like coming up
when you don't been in the streets
you're not going even no matter how
famous you get you're still going back
to call in everywhere you go you still
gonna make sure you sit in the corner
every restaurant by the exit
you never really get to enjoy life so
this is really my first time enjoying
life really
this is being freaked a gentleman like
you free state of mind gentlemen like
you
should have people around you securing
you
you know your friends i don't have to be
bodyguard to be your friends
the only thing you need is a pair of
eyes i'm going to go with god
i pay more attention when i'm by myself
oh boy
yeah do you like you like being you like
being like solo
you like spending i love it i have fun
by myself yeah
i go shopping i do all the normal [ __ ] i
just don't ever go to clubs and [ __ ]
unless i'm getting paid to go to a show
i'm always
i'm always by myself when i'm always
going to girls houses in the show and
nobody didn't know
as i always used to hang out by myself i
did that [ __ ] too but that should be
draining yeah
my skin like my skin got before i
started practicing
semen retention my skin got to looking
great but i noticed when i don't release
like say if i do have sex with a woman i
would have sex up until the point of
release but i hold back and i notice
that i'm stronger and everything i'm
mentally sharp in everything
it's just like when a woman after i give
my life forth to this woman
i don't have no energy i'm draining she
getting up cooking and manifesting all
the [ __ ] she want in her life
and i'm stuck with gray skin great skin
i never had gray skin what about you
no i just feel drained you know what i'm
saying
then you gotta go in the shower and do
it again
but it's something about after them 90
days you ain't released yeah
you're not coming back too quick you're
immortal
yeah how how do you find that balance
mike how do you find that balance in
your uh
in your life mike kid's wife
i'm pretty much of a slave to the
because
if you ask my kids what daddy do well
they know that was they were five years
old they said what did daddy do daddy
works for mommy
that's what they think
my children will say the same thing yeah
that's cool man
cause i'm like my wife really runs the
show yeah
that's how they see who the boss is
leaving the dog listening to my wife and
father my wife because she dictates the
house
yeah i don't know i don't want to deal
with that [ __ ] bills and all that
that's most like i am as far as with
business and everything i'll let my wife
deal with everything because
she's going for that [ __ ] i ain't got
time oh i'm just not
in it i'm my energy not there you're
talking to them people yeah
[ __ ] i don't understand what's wrong hey
mike we got a hundred million what we're
gonna do i'll talk to her
right now hey she knows yeah i don't
know about that
do you almost think it's a compatibility
mike like you almost have to be
sometimes you may like somebody but
doesn't mean you want to be with that
person
that's going to be meant for you for the
rest of your life you know what i'm
saying would you say it's compatibility
i'll be with them for the rest of my
life and we're not intimate
no no what i'm saying is you think
sometimes you know we may lust over a
person right
you may like somebody it may look good
but deep down inside man
you know that that apple is rotten you
know what i'm saying
i think um relationships have a lot to
do with um
criteria you know like if you ever look
at this um
movie a short movie called the science
of love
we really don't know why we fall in love
there's no science of why we fall
there's no nothing that can show
if you can see our hearts we look at a
person and they say you know
some people poop some people and then
sometimes you all you see something
like this it's what your eyes see but
it's just you have no control over it
the power of love i kind of to touch on
what you said about compatibility
sometimes well i could say
as me i [ __ ] i was going to say men but
i'm going to say me
i go on a relationship for the wrong
reasons
and i mean the wrong reason like if i
know this person's solid and she gonna
be there for me if i ever go to jail
so really that's fear making me stay in
this relationship
and she might be an amazing person but i
know that if i go back to jail
i know you're gonna run you're gonna
hold it down the horse legs ain't never
broke
you got me but then again like
like i say not that i didn't be doing a
lot of soul searching and just seeing
what it is that i really want
you look at this person in a different
light so
you fall in love with them all over
again or you grow a poor
people either grow together or they grow
apart and what i notice about
relationships it got to be worked on
every day it's not the man's fault it's
not the woman's fault
it's just we got to communicate and my
biggest thing was i'm not a communicator
as a man i expect you to just know
and i wouldn't work yeah i wouldn't
assert myself as a man
which a woman wants you to assert
yourself as a man and baby look this is
what we gonna do
i wasn't communicating you see that you
see that [ __ ] had today jesse lee
yeah if he would say that my daughter
he's really thinking my daughter would
really hurt him
yeah he said the woman got to obey the
man and we're from guard
oh no you ain't got to obey me but i
when i say asserting myself as a man as
far as baby this is what we doing
exactly this other guy was just [ __ ]
out of his [ __ ] mind he was cool
though it take communication like not
it's not a dictatorship but it takes
communication a lot of
um respect yeah but relationships are
interesting
but either we're going to grow together
we're going to grow apart and my
happiness comes first because if i'm not
happy
i can't make my children happy if me and
my wife have an argument my children
gonna feel it that there's gonna be
tension all throughout the household
so we're gonna have to start being
friends best friends again we're gonna
have to do 50 first dates
all over again i think that's the move
with adam sandler until we figure this
[ __ ] out
or whoever it is but listen sometimes
it's good you have to um go your
separate ways
yeah and then you realize why you love
that person or what it is that you miss
about that person or what makes that
person so amazing
because when you seeing some [ __ ] every
day that she could get boring
unless y'all making it y'all a point to
spice the relationship up and keep it
spicy
i never get bored of my wife because my
wife sometimes
talks too much [ __ ] i never get bored
sometimes you need this hey cool is all
right i'm sorry
i like to be challenged too though i
liked it that's like having a tiger that
could talk like
oh [ __ ] i like when you get aggressive
with me
you was gonna kill me in my sleep
you ever slept with the knife no i i
don't i don't associate with people like
that
no i have to go to sleep with one eye
[Laughter]
what's gonna happen gonna happen anyway
i'm not living like that because nobody
wants to hurt me
everyone wants to love me right
too much love makes me to relapse
did that mushroom kick in mike no um
i did not expect this podcast to go like
this
what happened nothing this is a good
podcast
you know you come in with ex kind of
like expectations
this is this is every day right this
[ __ ] is just thugging
hey listen this is every day we buy
money and we get high here kev
yeah this is
yeah man so kevin tell me something
how do you follow your kids do you take
them out and [ __ ] i do everything with
them
everything yeah they come here with you
they not here right now cause they got
school
so they doing school like on a computer
like zombies
actually once a week my son go to marco
my son go to saudi with me
my son and pray to medina with me they
go wherever i go they go to morocco with
me
they go to mexico with me they go
everywhere my son needs to see that the
way that i treat men
and the way that i conduct myself in
public because he's a hands-on learner
he learned from experience
he don't learn from me telling them what
to do because i never learned from
nobody telling me what to do
i'm a visual person i got to see it yeah
and kevin this has been very interesting
i just saw you say was are you speaking
arabic right now yeah i'm making
that rum i'm real high my no you're
gonna get higher in the moment
mike you can do more shoes than anybody
i've ever met dude can you
you guys think he'd get the guinness
book of world records and uh
what am i doing now i'm just gonna bring
that home with me be hanging out my
[ __ ] are they colder than
chocolate
yeah good [ __ ] [ __ ] making shit's good
kevin
stop that [ __ ] [ __ ] take it you sure
[ __ ] i'll promise
i'm the designated driver oh
this so would you ever do anything any
like celebrity boxing dude would you
ever box somebody and uh
no no what's your take on that
i saw you hitting the mitts in the the
music video
how did that fight [ __ ] um chris rock
no i like chris wright i like krishna
what's what's one celebrity fight you'd
like to see celebrity fight
yeah if you had to pick two celebrities
or or who would you like to see
maybe kevin's gate to it duking it out i
don't think they fight my [ __ ]
body [ __ ] i don't even like the fight
the mac max don't fight right
oh man it's a beautiful batman i am so
high
man kevin gates you got any last words
man you wanted
a bunch of 100 million [ __ ]
looking at you so you should say some
[ __ ]
maybe you want to sell something tell
them how much you love
along anything man
this has been an experience like when i
first came i thought we was going to
talk about
how you did you know mushrooms how you
did the toad
how you did are you we could have talked
about that you should have told me we're
going to talk all right
but i i wanted to let you lead you might
ain't want to talk about it
yeah i watched the interview with you
that's what i thought we was going to
cover here talking about
[ __ ] all right now listen i did the
toad i was a [ __ ]
110 pounds overweight yeah like that's
that's what got me focused when you got
to talk about the native american
medicine i was like
i did the toad i went back to i was not
that well he might know
what led up to me he might know
something all your ancestors and you
right now you say wow this all led up to
me
it's beyond my um comprehension i can't
really really either
articulate it beyond my thinking
yeah and then i was watching the
interview where you was talking about
ayahuasca yeah your wife got me violent
i didn't like that
high yeah but um i stick with the
shrooms and the talk
i got a question when you did ayahuasca
did you do it in ceremony
like with a chief or did you just do it
we deal with some rich [ __ ] and
i think
i went in there with the negative [ __ ]
and um
yeah i just [ __ ] the party up i'm not
gonna say which thing but
my experience with plant medicine
was i didn't want to do no man-made
drugs no more
never happened to me i ain't going to do
no man-made drugs
that's what god did that's what i
thought we was about to talk about
because i watched the one where you were
talking about the toad
i made all the money the whole year
nobody made money more money than me
that yeah
and i into the [ __ ] toad and they
said no i'm fighting somebody
and then like when you were saying how
it destroyed the ego oh kevin listen
right
just know one thing if you don't got an
ego man we ain't nobody else like that
we need that either people think he goes
the enemy
yeah i'm there he's enlightened brother
matter of fact redwood don't you got a
couple of
boxes of this stuff don't you i love you
so kindly he's a kind man
very giving as well so what's going on
here man
who else you did um collabs with
i didn't work with almost everybody in
the industry but
i mean i don't look at that as an
accolade
i don't like you kabo you know you
didn't been there that [ __ ] don't matter
after you cross over what what what you
what have made you feel that you have
accomplished
a form of your goal what what what part
of this
um part of your job of trapping you feel
you um
accomplish your goal um
i was sitting in the studio session the
other day and one of my annoys was like
you know you number three globally on
youtube
and i was like wow
i was like that's amazing and it's like
the whole my whole life i was trying to
get to this
point and get there and get there and
get down working so hard to get there i
don't know where there is
and then it was like the place i was
trying to get
i was already there i just seen one i
hate to even say who it was i'm not
going to say well what but i just seen
a brother that's very dear to me in the
rap game and
he turned up but when i seen him i was
like i don't want to trade places with
you
like i don't like i can dig
it you know i don't want to trade places
with you it's like i was always trying
to get there but i was already there
and it's like my whole life just making
comparisons like
i don't know i'm real competitive you
have to be i'm
competitive in half the even this like i
look at
i look at when i'm about to make an
album i'm looking at it like i'm
training for a fight
i work out every day yeah no six no
alcohol no nothing not like i'm it's
like i'm training for a fight
and i feel like if you make an album and
you're not scared
and you ain't got butterflies in your
stomach and you're not scared
then you're not putting everything into
it yeah that's what they saying fighting
if you're not scared
it's time to stop fighting
you know next time whenever you go in
the ring you don't have that fear
it's time to give it up you're big on
that mic
what do you think what do you think that
is mike what god gives us fear to
protect
ourselves but they feel good when you
face it
oh you have to face it and understand
that it's just uh it's just
another part of just another part of the
emotion right fear's an
illusion that's what it is no but would
you say is
it's another part of a it's an emotion
that we have to accept too
fear yeah we have to embrace it we have
to embrace it
for me i like fear because it keeps me
sharp it keeps me polished
and it's like it keep me it's what's
gonna make me push myself to that extra
the extra point if you if you train hard
then the fight gonna be easy
you know if i if i prepared like for
this album i'd put everything into it
i'm really rid of the rep
cause i put everything into it blood
sweating
fail the prepare you prepare to fail
that's old school what advice would you
give uh
kevin gates here man what advice would
you give him never stop believing in
yourself
don't ever the power of belief is just
unbearable impregnable power belief
confidence breeds success and success
breathes confidence
confidence applied properly with the
pastor genius
it's not like the belief it's real [ __ ]
right i'm only here because i believe
really believe this [ __ ]
oh oh [ __ ] [ __ ] in debt on a [ __ ] i
have
[ __ ] like 60 million dollars of tax
debt yeah
got out of that [ __ ] got into this [ __ ]
you had yeah where did this money come
from you know how
you know i just that's why i don't
accept it and i give away because
you know i don't deserve this [ __ ]
nobody really deserves that kind of
money
yeah give me a break how do you how
would you feel if i have you had 300
million
and he's your friend he don't got
anything
is that really um is that really
enterprise
you think that's where a lot of you
bring that up a lot might you think
that's where a lot of your
your money you gave a lot of money away
online yeah yeah
and what happened look what happened it
came back
you know so i'm trying to stay humble
because my wife keeps me humble but you
know
sometimes you gotta talk that [ __ ] to
yourself sometime when i'm in the
sometime when i'm when you know when i'm
at the house sometimes i'm hey [ __ ] we
having too much of this [ __ ]
sometimes you gotta tell yourself that
sometimes you
to turn up sometimes it's cool to be
humble like i'm very humble
but sometimes i gotta give myself a pat
on the back and let myself know
hey hey gays [ __ ] we did it cause i'm
my own best friend and maybe this come
from doing a lot of time juvenile
attention to
to adult jail [ __ ] like that i'm always
by myself
so sometimes i like to pat myself on the
back and tell myself hey [ __ ] we did it
we having too much of this [ __ ] man but
that's your loser you're never by
yourself
right you know right now somebody
somebody's telling me what's what you're
saying right now doing something
something's telling you to say that
you're saying that by yourself
yes system told you to say yes sir
you're not by yourself
like you know when i go to psychiatrists
they say do you hear voices
i want to say yeah [ __ ] i hear voices
but if you say that the [ __ ] goes to
all those people with the white jacket
and you're going to be [ __ ] up
but you know you hear voices
i all geniuses talk to themselves
all geniuses talk to themselves they
like talking to smart people
that's why right all geniuses talk to
themselves
most of the problems that i didn't
figure out they came from me talking to
myself and figuring it out
i tell my wife why are you talking to
yourself i like to talk to smart people
okay oh genius
my kids are you talk to yourself my kids
are freaked out you talk to yourself
[ __ ] right
[ __ ] right that's how i got you all
this [ __ ] talking to myself i'm loud in
the bathroom who you talking to
man it's just me
your whole house is [ __ ] up
but they didn't got used to it though
because i walk around talking to myself
you talk to yourself get away from me
sometimes when i'm running on the trip
here i'm running on the treadmill doing
the full speed sprinter i'll be like
come here [ __ ] don't you run from me
and it just
it just that's what motivated me to keep
going so it's just
got my kids and daddy you talking or
something that runs for me
[Laughter]
you have full blown out conversations
mike with yourself dude
i like i like talking to intelligent
people you ever play out scenarios
like how you think things may go off no
i listen
i'm deep in there i know how it's going
to go i don't even go to no scenario
i ain't going to say it like that but
i'll already be knowing like listen
right this is the deal with more shrooms
right
i mean the worst thing for me to do is
being shrooms alone but when you get
mushrooms alone
it [ __ ] with you tells you i hope it
builds up your confidence ability it
makes you
good you feel like god and then they say
hey remember you did that thing that
some
such and such before what do you think
about that you think that was really
nice
and he said whoa what's that about hey
remember you did that to such and
and then i mean he was [ __ ] he got
the guilt chip on you like oh my god
i'm ready my wife hey baby baby baby
come back come on yeah
she don't like me babe i'm sorry i did
shoot and it's [ __ ] with me but
there's balance
that's boundless that's balanced i'm
sure i'm gonna start getting my
my confidence something to say then
bring back the [ __ ] i used to do
the bad say why you do this but you
think that was cool
no but you think that's what you think
that's a bad thing mike no i think
i think um um what's the word i wanted
to use i think this
i think is such an evolving moment in my
life
dealing with who i am and not being
ashamed before i am
right that's been my whole journey you
know not being ashamed and nothing
yeah they just free mike yeah
it's just uh you know you don't belong
to a party
yeah how can i not be i i'm not
i'm a republican i'm a democrat i'm
everything how can i not be
in a party yeah i'm here on earth i'm
i'm
politics people up look the black
community we are politics how can you
not be in politics
your existence is politics yeah
no it is our existence of politics on
what somebody say this is our lifestyle
now
so you have to be a politician you have
to you are you are born a politic
well you have any uh special words kevin
gates to say for mike
nah i enjoyed it it would fly i miss on
these streams and i'm feeling so
beautiful
[Laughter]
no i got what i needed to get it's
beautiful success breathes confidence
confidence breathes success
like i just said when i first came here
i don't know what i'm doing
but i know that i'm on the right path i
just know that i know
as long as you know what to stay away
from that's really
that's the real all things are
moderation
some things can't be done in moderation
like what heroin
no no but i don't play that that's
something somebody made everything in
moderation that's [ __ ]
can't do heroin in moderation
coke and moderate but it was medicine at
one time
because we abused it it was heroin was
medicine at one time
they sold it at the local drug stores
they were built in the 20s
turn of the century all that stuff
coca-cola that's what
it was known for having coke in there
so why are you talking about he laughing
[ __ ]
dude those things are strong oh yeah i'm
[ __ ]
on mount olympus right now
[Laughter]
oh man you guys just watched an episode
of hotbox and i'm your co-host triple c
aka henry cejudo i'm mike tyson
and we had a great guest kevin gates mr
gates
uh we're out
you